una columna de humo se eleva sobre los
suburbios de una zona en la que el
ejército ucraniano acaba de Recuperar el
control ha sido liberada de los rusos
pero siguen disparando cohetes y
artillería los ucranianos están
trasladando sus armas a nuevas
posiciones para proteger la ciudad los
habitantes apenas tiemblan cuando
disparan pero muchos están huyendo las
casas Están en ruinas y las ciudades
están lejos de ser segura las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas se enfrentan a un
reto defender sus recientes logros al
tiempo que continúan la contraofensiva
gran pertenece al batallón de fuerzas
especiales que perforó las primeras
líneas de defensa rusas en esta zona uno
de los comandantes del Batallón de
nombre claver nos dice que los rusos se
ven obstaculizados por sus estructuras
de mando por nuestra parte las
decisiones sobre el terreno las toman
rápidamente los comandantes que están
presentes tienen mucho margen de
maniobra para decidir pero el ejército
ruso sigue amarrado a un sistema
vertical sino reciben luz verde del
oficial de mayor Rango la Infantería no
se mueve necesitan la confirmación de la
cúpula O no hacen nada eso nos permite
aplastarlo 50 kilómetros al sur o
Alexander y lo inspeccionan las orillas
del Río osquil La línea de frente
a nosotros están esos bastardos rusos
nuestro trabajo es comprobar que nadie
cruza y nadie localiza nuestras
posiciones para evitar que nuestra
artillería y blindaje sean destruidos no
debemos dejar pasar a sus grupos de
reconocimiento también nos aseguramos de
que no se acerquen los rusos que quedan
en este lado del río los que no lograron
escapar al otro lado
todavía hay muchos soldados rusos
atrapados en el lado ucraniano del río
esta semana la unidad de olexander
capturó a 10 de ellos algunos se
escondían en los juncos de la oria del
Río